if you remember we said that a
neural neural network has a basic component which we call
the perceptron and the perceptual is supposed
to be a mathematical model.
of a human brain neuron
and a neuron will pass a signal.
Forward if the signal is strong enough.
In the context of networks if it's relevant enough the
value of function.
Well established.
threshold
so the value is for
setting a threshold.
Let me show you something else. I did not talk about.
This is slide 108 if I return to 152.
You will notice we have these arrows.
These arrows are biases.
So this is the one x-axis.
And let's say the x-axis is the size of the property.
And the y-axis is the activation.
the strength of the signal so to speak
so the y axis is the activation.
This is actually the size of the property times.
the weight
the random weight. So let's say if I come
back to our slides. I think it was W sub 2i,
but it's a wait just a wait just
some random weight
Okay.
and here the bias is set to zero,
which means
It is zero.
so the origin
okay.
if I return to this unbiased activation
function
I don't like to use the word unbias because it has a specific meanings
statistics.
but if you look at this activation function here
the bias is set to zero.
So which means that I mean, it's like an if enough statement right
f of x will give you 0
for any value of x that is less than
zero. So basically any negative numbers that is negative really is
going to
squishy to zero
but if any value is equal to zero or above 0
and then you will get a you will get the linear you will get an identity.
So if you get 5
You basically rally will let it
through as long as it's above zero.
suppose
this is our
customized value
and then we will say it is the function
represented by f of x.
And this will be a piecewise function. So begin.
It will give you.
zero
if
the value of x is
greater than
the bias
Excuse me.
Less than the bias.
and it will give you
X
itself
if
it is equal to
basically greater than or equal to the bias.
Like a simple if anal statement.
If it's less than biased.
zero equal to above bias
X letter through
So, let me tell you what device does let me
ask a question.
how
Big does a property have to be.
What is the minimum minimal size the smallest of
property has to be for to
be considered?
Either an office or an apartment.
200 square feet
we will set the bias.
To be good to 200. Basically we are doing this.
If we set the Bice 200, we're going to
shift this.
200 points to the right
imagine if I bring it over here.
Okay.
We have shifted.
the bias 200 points
Okay, what are we doing here?
Suppose we take we have some property.
And I will use this point to represent that problem. Let's make this a
very small observation.
Okay.
this represents
the size times weight
of this property
if the property is
100 I can't even put it exactly on
the
property is 150 square feet.
Because it is below our threshold.
We don't even consider the property.
So it's activation will be zero.
so
f of x or if you or equivalently if you want five
of x
I want to be consistent with the slides.
The activation for this particular X will
be zero.
Because it's not a property.
What if we make it one, you know
190 still not a property. It's not qualified
to be a property.
But once it gets to 200 or above. Oh, well, then
we will let it through.
That's what I mean by strength of the signal.
If we had a stack of hidden layers, it would not even get to
the next year because what's the point of figuring because see
the way we're going to determine if it's a office or
a real estate is to see how big it is how many
partitions?
How many windows the height of
the ceiling may be?
How many fire extinguishers?
How many glass because of Open
Space is really they have these glass?
Like you don't have well like you have we
have a beat you have view like glass Glass Walls. I
don't know how to call it.
So what's the point of counting the number of
rooms and the height of the ceiling and the number of fire extinguishers if
it's even if it's too small to even be considered
an apartment, that's what this value is going to
do.
So if I return you if I return here to the
slides if I
return to one five two
That's what we try to indicate it. So if you see here, let's say the
okay this one this activation function
for this example. The bias is set to 0.
So when we take this sum of this product 32 because 32
is above the bias it will we will let it
through same thing for 55 with letter through but
for negative four, we crush it down to zero.
then once we get to this point
We will also do we will
multiply this activation by its weight.
This activation by its weight this activation by its
weight.
So this one?
Since the signal was very weak.
It will remain zero even when it reaches this
downstairs. So for example
Let's say this particular property.
has
its size is below the
threshold.
That's already a red flag. It's not big enough for us
to consider the property.
but it has a door and it has
a window
But because this signal from this perception is
very weak.
And we have another activation function here. We will
classify it as not property.
but I talked about binary classification, so
I guess it could be.
a very small office
Like, you know when you go to currency exchange.
They have these very small booths. So I guess
you can call that an office.
The example I'm giving is
not perfect, but hopefully understand the purpose of the rally function.
That's really what I'm trying to emphasize you.